the announcement of today's president
trump's pick to replace
justice ruth bader ginsburg on the
supreme court the president is expected
to select
amy coney barrett a federal judge who
currently sits on the seventh circuit
court of appeals
the nomination comes a little more than
a week after ginsburg's death
and just 38 days before the presidential
election
setting up a pitched partisan battle
over the pivotal seat
on the highest court in the land the
president will make the announcement
formally this afternoon at the white
house that's where ben tracy is
ben good morning good morning you know
judge amy coney barrett always appeared
to be president trump's first choice
even though he said he was considering
five different women
well he will make it official here at
the white house today in the rose garden
at a late night rally in virginia friday
president trump teased his big
announcement
the only thing i can tell you for sure
is it will be a woman
is that okay according to multiple
sources familiar with the selection
process
the president is expected to nominate
48-year-old appeals court judge
amy coney barrett she's very highly
respected i can say that
barrett is a favorite of religious
conservatives for her strong
anti-abortion rights views
and if confirmed would move the court to
the right for a generation
in 2016 she said she doesn't think roe v
wade will be entirely overturned
but access to abortion would be
restricted i don't think the
the core case that rose core holding
that you know women have a right to an
abortion i don't think that would change
but i think the question of
whether people can get very late term
abortions you know how many restrictions
can be put on clinics i think that would
change
president trump first considered barrett
when filling justice anthony kennedy's
seat
after he retired in 2018. he nominated
judge brett kavanaugh instead
but that meant barrett was already
vetted by the white house and republican
leaders in congress feel confident
they can quickly confirm her before
election day to replace the liberal icon
ruth bader ginsburg
the late justice was remembered during a
ceremony at the capitol friday
honored not just for her 27 years on the
nation's highest court
but for her trailblazing role in
fighting for equality for women
she was our prophet our north star
our strength for so very long
and now the focus turns to what is
expected to be a fierce fight
over president trump's nominee and then
what happens on capitol hill
is a partisan battle that uh honestly
will be probably the most disgusting
thing that we've seen
since judge kavanaugh cbs news has
learned that the white house is already
reaching out to republican senators to
set up meetings with the nominee for
next week
and you know president trump has made no
secret about the fact that he thinks the
election could be so close that it's
decided by the supreme court
and he wants his nominee confirmed
before november third dana
all right ben thank you